The original texture is just fine, it's a square. Even if it were distorted in
some funny way, why the upper left of the texture would be different than the
lower right isn't clear. The second answer is incorrect. Three JS may have some
bugs in it but this is not one of them. The third answer is interesting. In
fact if the square was made out of a fine mesh of triangles, depending on how
the triangles were created when the square was worked, could make the
distortion look more natural. The fourth answer is indeed the reason. If you
tried the show polygon option in the demo, you'd see the two triangles. Since
the square is made of two triangles, moving the corner of the upper left
triangle has no effect on the triangle in the lower right. I highly recommend
reading the article that is listed in the additional course materials. It
discusses this and a number of other common rendering problems.